monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues et l'immigration est une
chance pour la france
tel est depuis une trentaine d'années la
devise sinon de la république du moins
d'une classe politique qui a toujours
nié jusqu'à laisser mourir l'identité du
peuple français
regroupement familial effacement des
frontières discrimination positive al
embauche assistanat social droit d'asile
faux mineurs mais vrai clandestins
majeur vous avez créé toutes les
conditions d'une véritable submersion
migratoire alors l'immigration est une
chance mais pour qui assurément pas pour
nos compatriotes pour une caste
politique elle a permis de sauver
quelques élections grâce à ces nouveaux
français
pour d'autres elle a permis de recevoir
des subventions publiques et d'affréter
des bateaux pour amener des clandestins
des côtes libyennes jusqu'à en europe
les chiffres sont éloquents en 2016
seuls 7% des étrangers qui se sont
installés chez nous était muni d'un
contrat d'embauché l'émigration n'est
plus est depuis longtemps une
immigration de travail mais une
immigration de peuplement pour assistés
sociaux pour nos compatriotes
la facture est exorbitante je vous le
dis solennellement mes chers collègues
je ne crois pas à la théorie du grand
remplacement en revanche je suis
convaincu de sa réalité
je vais vous ferez pas moi le bruit le
bruit et les odeurs si chère au
président disparu
mais ces zones qui se comptent par
centaines à travers le pays qui sont
devenus des enclaves étrangères des
zones de non france où la haine de tout
ce qui est français se répand comme une
traînée de poudre
nos lois notre culture notre identité
notre savoir vivre notre savoir être nos
libertés celle des femmes en particulier
comme les libertés sexuelles et
religieuses sont rejetés combattu pour
être elle aussi remplacé sous les coups
d'un communautarisme
islamistes militants l'idéologie du
vivre ensemble c'est croule sous le
poids de la réalité d'une immigration
chaque jour plus violentes et
conquérante et met en danger notre unité
nationale et républicaine
seuls ceux qui en ont les moyens en
réchappe et parmi ceux là vous tous ou
presque mes chers collègues car si la
classe politique est favorable au vivre
ensemble
elle ne s'inflige pas le vivre avec
l'immigration c'est comme les éoliennes
ce qui en défendant l'installation
refuse d'en voir à côté de chez eux
votre politique d'immigration mes chers
collègues a aussi le coût du sang du
bataclan à nice de laura maurane à
timothy watteo c'est notre jeunesse qui
est sacrifié sur l'autel d'une idéologie
destructrice sur le plan social la
politique d'immigration relève de la
provocation
alors que chaque jour de nouveaux
sacrifices sont exigés des français
l'immigration continue d'être un tonneau
des danaïdes
le coût de la hem qui bénéficie aux
seuls clandestins est passé de 400
millions il y a quinze ans à 1 milliard
d'euros aujourd'hui les français ne s'y
trompent plus ou plutôt vous ne les
trompe et plus ils sont majoritaires en
refuser ce suicide national des français
en ont marre les français en ont assez
car en tant qu ils se poussent qu'ils
consentent les sacrifices qu'ils
accueillent l'autre
et quand ils ont obtenu en retour le
développement d'un insupportable racisme
antifrançais et anti blancs
antichrétiens nos compatriotes refuse la
submersion et de devenir des étrangers
dans leur propre pays
alors vous menacez vous censurer et vous
traîner devant les tribunaux ces
résistants qui refusent de collaborer
comment pouvez vous avoir les yeux aussi
grands fermés devant le ce phénomène
unique dans l'histoire de l'humanité et
des nations
celui de l'explosion démographique
mondiale loin d'en prendre conscience et
fidèle à son en même temps emmanuel
macron parcourt l'europe pour
sanctionner les pays qui refusent les
quotas de migrants et il s'apprête de
faire affaire pardon de marseille un
port d'accueil pour les clandestins de
la méditerranée marseille
marcel et qui subit déjà une situation
migratoire social et sécuritaire
explosive une provocation que je
continuerai à défendre et à dénoncer
pardon comme c'est le cas depuis comme
c'est le cas depuis longtemps et même si
cela doit me coûter une mise en examen
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui car dans
ce beau pays de france
un parlementaire qui dénonce un trafic
d'êtres humains se retrouve devant les
tribunaux
face à ce danger mortel qui menacent
notre nation et l'europe de charlemagne
de charles martel de charles quint
personnes nous fera taire mais nous
attendons bien autre chose que de ce
faux débat
les seules questions qui devraient vous
mais son seul là avant nous nous
français le droit de vivre en france
selon nos traditions et notre identité
avons nous le droit de rester ce que
nous sommes et de transmettre à nos
enfants ce que nous avons reçu de nos
parents dont nous le droit de demeurer
français dans une france française
nous connaissons la réponse et le
sursaut national ne peut donc venir
d'aucun d'entre vous aussi pour toutes
les victimes de votre folle politique
d'immigration pour les victimes sociales
économiques et identitaires pour toutes
ces familles dont la vie a été détruite
sous les coups de l'immigration sauvage
je vous demande mes chers collègues de
droite comme de gauche car vous êtes
tous responsables de ce désastre
je vous demande de vous excuser excusez
vous pour avoir menti
excusez vous il va falloir qu aucune
excuse et vous je conclu monsieur le
président merci
excusez vous en instaurant la préférence
nationale dans tous les domaines en
rétablissant les frontières en mettant
en place des quotas n'ont pas
d'immigration mais des quotas
d'expulsion excusez vous en inversant le
courant de l'immigration
si vous refusez faut qu'on ne sait pas
votre idéologie mortifère
bien avant la postérité c'est la france
qui vous le monde ira
[Applaudissements]